♪♪
>> CNN IS TRYING TO COVER FOR
ENBATTLED ANCHOR CHRIS CUOMO
WHILE HE AND HIS BROTHER DROWN
IN SCANDAL CHRIS FACING WRIT
SWITCH FOR REFUSING TO COVER THE
STORY BUT GETTING SUPPORT FROM
THE EDUCATE NETWORK'S SO CALLED
CRITICS.
>> THIS IS A CON UNDRUM FOR CNN
THAT HAVE NO PERFECT ANSWER OR
SOLUTION.
SOME PEOPLE SAY CNN MADE IT
WORSE WHEN CHRIS WAS ALLOWED TO
INTERVIEWS HIS BROTHER WHEN HE
WAS NEW YORK.
THAT WAS UNPRECEDENTED.
AND SO IS THIS, A FAMOUS FAMILY
IN THE NEWS A GOVERNOR AT THE
HIGHEST HEIGHTS NOW TO THE
LOWEST LOWS.
SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS.
AND A BROTHER WHO JUST WANTS TO
DO HIS JOB.
JUST WANTS TO ANCHOR HIS SHOW.
>> GREG, THE FAMOUS FAMILY IS
HAVING A HARD TIME AND, QUOTE,
CHRIS CUOMO HAS A LOT TO SAY BUT
HE CANNOT SAY IT.
>> I'M HAVING TOO MUCH PLEASURE
RIGHT NOW FROM EVERYTHING HE
JUST SAID.
HE'S THE MEDIA REPORTER.
WOULD HE HAVE ADDRESSED THE
NUANCE OF THIS TOPIC IF IT HAD
HAPPENED AT FOX NEWS?
>> NO.
>> SUDDENLY HE'S DISCOVERED THE
COMPLEXITY OF LIFE, THE
COMPLEXITY OF REPORTING.
BEFORE IT WAS JUST TRUMP
SUPPORTERS RACIST.
THAT WAS SO EASY.
AND FOX NEWS SHOULD BE TAKEN OFF
THE AIR.
WE DIDN'T NEED ANY NUANCE THEN.
BUT NOW I NEED NUANCE.
MY FAVORITE PART ABOUT IT IS
THAT'S SO SELTZER.
HE WENT TO HIS SOURCES, RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW, HE WENT INTO THE
BREAK ROOM AND HE FOUND OUT THAT
CHRIS CUOMO JUST WANTS TO DO HIS
JOB.
SO I'M BEGINNING TO WONDER WHAT
IS THE ANONYMOUS SOURCE, WHO
THAT WAS?
WAS THAT LIKE THE CAFETERIA LADY
OR SOME ITALIAN GUY WHO'S
BROTHER'S GOVERNOR.
JUST SAY I WANT TO DO MY JOB.
I LOVE SEEING THE SPOTLIGHT
TURNED ON THEM AND WATCHING
THEIR BEHAVIOR CHANGE.
IT'S REFRESHING TO SEE THEM
SUDDENLY DISCOVER THAT LIFE
ISN'T AS SIMPLE AS THEY'VE BEEN
PLAYING IT.
THEY HAVE ASSIGNED SO MUCH
SIMPLISTIC BLAME TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR TEN YEARS.
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> THERE WAS NO NUANCE ABOUT
COPS.
IF THERE WAS ONE COP THAT DID
SOMETHING BAD, IT WAS THE ENTIRE
POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT WAS
GUILTY OF SYSTEMIC RACISM.
RIGHT?
THERE WAS NO NUANCE THERE.
THERE WAS NO NUANCE ANYTIME A
TRUMP SUPPORTER POSTED A MEME.
CLEARLY THAT MEANS ALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WERE RACIST.
THERE WAS NEVER NUANCE.
NOW THEY FIGURED IT OUT.
GOOD JOB.
>> CNN IS TRYING TO MAKE THIS
SOUND LIKE THERE'S A CONFLICT
WITH CHRIS CUOMO CORING HIS
BROTHER ANDREW CUOMO.
>> CONVENIENT.
>> BUT THAT'S DEFENSE OF THE
SITUATION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY ABOUT CHRIS
CUOMO WRITING STATEMENTS AND
E-MAILS THAT THEN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ACTUALLY SENT OUT ALMOST
VERBATIM ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNOR DURING THE SCANDAL.
SO THERE ARE LAYERS TO THIS THAT
THEY'RE NOT WANTING TO GET INTO.
>> OF COURSE.
EVEN ON THE JOURNALISTIC ETHICAL
LEVEL THAT'S CONVENIENT TO TAKE
WHERE YOU WERE PERFECTLY FINE
COVERING HIM WHEN HE WAS BEING
LAUDED AND GIVEN EMMY AWARDS.
BUT NOW THERE'S CRITICISM
THERE'S CONFLICT OF INTEREST
HERE.
BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
KATIE IT DOESN'T STOP THERE
BECAUSE CHRIS CUOMO ISN'T JUST
COVERING THE STORY HE IS PART OF
THE STORY HELPING TO CRAFT THE
MESSAGE FOR GOVERNOR CUOMO.
I LOOK AT THIS QUICKLY AND I
THINK HOW DOES GOVERNOR CUOMO
HOLD ON.
RIGHT NOW HE'S LOST POLITICAL
PARTY, LOST POLLING IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK, LOST EVERY
LEGISLATE YOU ARE IN ABOUT THE
STATE.
AND THE ONLY ANSWER IS THE ONE
THAT KEEPS CHRIS CUOMO IN HIS
JOB AND THAT IS WE ARE WATCHING
PRIVILEGE PLAY OUT.
SOMEONE TALKED ABOUT PRIVILEGE.
THIS IS FAME, A POLITICAL
FAMILY.
THIS IS PEOPLE BORN ON THIRD
BASE AND THINK THEY HIT A TRIPLE
AND CAN'T IMAGINE THE WORLD IS
GOING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS COMPLETELY FOR BOTH
BROTHERS A STORY OF PRIVILEGE.
>> DOES THE GOVERNOR STAY OR GO.
>> FIRST I WANT TO SAY I
ACTUALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT SPORTS
IN ET FOR AND I'M PROUD OF
MYSELF.
IT WAS A VERY GOOD ONE.
COUPLE THINGS HAPPENED THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND.
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF RESIGNED
TODAY SO NOT ONLY HAS HE LOST
THE PEOPLE WILL JUST MENTIONED
BUT WHEN SHE WHO ENABLED A LOT
OF THIS REALIZES THAT SHE BETTER
HOP OFF OF THIS TRAIN AND TRY TO
SAVE HERSELF, IF SHE CAN,
BECAUSE SHE'S ALSO GOING TO BE A
WITNESS IN ALL OF THIS, SO SHE
LEFT.
THE OTHER THING I DID NOT
REALIZE IS THAT, ONCE
IMPEACHMENT STARTS IN THE STATE
OF NEW YORK, HE HAS TO STEP
ASIDE AS GOVERNOR.
OKAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE WHEN WE SAW THE
CONGRESS IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
TWICE WHERE HE'S STILL AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND IT'S OVER
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING
TO PASS, IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
HE ACTUALLY HAS TO LEAVE.
SO I DO THINK BECAUSE YOU SAW
HIS TEAM FLOAT AN IDEA TODAY, A
DEAL, IN WHICH HE BASICALLY
WOULD SAY TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I PROMISE NOT TO RUN
FOR A FOURTH TERM IF YOU DON'T
TRY TO IMPEACH ME.
TO ME I THIS THINK HE KNOWS ONE
HE'S NOT RUNNING FOR A FOURTH
TERM ANYWAY AND TWO HE KNOWS IF
HE GETS IMPEACHED IT'S ALL OVER
AND HE KNOWS HE'S GOING TO GET
IMPEACHED.
SO I DON'T THINK -- I DON'T KNOW
HOW HE LEAVES BUT HE LEAVES.
>> JESSICA THERE WAS ANOTHER BIG
RESIGNATION AS WELL TODAY.
THE LEADER OF THE TIME'S UP
MOVEMENT WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT DEFENDING WOMEN FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AT WORK, ROBERTA KAPLAN.
SHE ACTUALLY WAS HELPING
GOVERNOR CUOMO GO AFTER THE
WOMEN WHO WERE ACCUSING HIM OF
DOING ALL THESE THINGS AND
CORROBORATED IN THIS REPORT WE
SAW COME OUT.
SO THERE'S THAT LAYER TOO, THIS
TIME'S UP HOLLYWOOD MOVEMENT ON
THE LEFT SUPPOSED TO BE STANDING
UP FOR WOMEN AND THE WOMAN
RUNNING THE SHOW WAS ACTUALLY
HELPING TO SMEAR THE REPUTATIONS
TO WOMEN COMING FORWARD.
>> THIS IS REALLY A CONTINUATION
OF THE STORY WE'VE BEEN SEEING
IN THE AFTERMATH OF, YOU KNOW,
THE BEGINNING OF TIME'S UP WHERE
PEOPLE REALIZED ACTUALLY THESE
STORIES ARE INCREDIBLY TEXTURED
AND THEY'RE DIFFERENT IN CASES,
LIKE YOU REMEMBER THE BEGINNING
SUDDENLY HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND AL
FRANK INARE THE SAME PERSON
WHICH IS LUDICROUS AND I THINK
AL FRANKEN IS SITTING THERE
SAYING I CANNOT BELIEVE I
RESIGNED AFTER SEEING WHAT WE
SAW HAPPEN THERE.
SO IT WAS RIGHT FOR HER TO
RESIGN AND I DO AS SOMEONE, THE
ONLY MEMBER OF THE LIBERAL PARTY
AT THE TABLE, I CAN TELL YOU
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE SAME
POLITICS AS ME HAS SHIFTED AWAY
FROM BELIEVING IN ORGANIZATIONS
OR SHIFTING IN ORGANIZATIONS TO
MOVING CASE-BY-CASE BASIS THIS
IS WHAT I THINK ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE.
AND GREG AND I WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS BEFORE WE CAME OUT
HERE.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR CUOMO SCANDAL
SHIFTED FROM THE NURSING HOMES
TO ME TOO, THAT'S WHEN I SAID
THIS IS NOT GOING TO END WELL
FOR HIM BECAUSE I THINK THAT
PEOPLE WERE A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLE AND FELT LIKE THERE
WAS MORE FODDER TO GO AFTER HIM
ON THIS WHERE IT SEEMS -- THESE
ARE VERY REAL ACCUSATIONS, AND
IT DID NOT MAKE HER HAPPY, I'M
SURE, TO HAVE TO RELEASE THAT
REPORT.
THERE WAS LIKE 11-PLUS WOMEN.
SO THEY KNEW THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF SOCIETY
CAN GET BEHIND.
RIGHT?
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
COME OUT WITH AND YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO WAS
FORCED TO, AND I'M SURE HE
CALLED CUOMO AHEAD OF TIME AND
SAID I SAID ON STEPHANOPOULOS IF
THE REPORT IS BAD THAT YOU'RE
GOING AND THAT WAS THE STANDARD
YOU WANTED US TO HOLD YOU TOEN A
I I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR DECADES AND
I LOVED YOUR DAD BUT THIS IS THE
STANDARD.
>> WELL, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
DENIED THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
CALLED ANDREW CUOMO DIRECTLY.
>> SORRY.
>> THE PRIME MINISTER CALLED.
>> YEAH, RON KLAIN MAY HAVE
CALLED BUT THE OTHER THING ON
THE NURSING HOME ISSUE IS IT
WASN'T JUST CUOMO THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
INVOLVED IN NURSING HOMES SO
ONCE AGAIN IT'S EASY TO WALK
AWAY FROM THAT.